So speaking of my mother I want to show
you
these beautiful beautiful things that my
aunt just said to me I had no idea they
existed make them big make everyone be
able to see them these are paintings
get them up get both of them up
these are paintings that my mother did
before she died these are
paintings
I believe they are maybe watercolor on
canvas acrylic on canvas I don't know
they are
they mean a lot to me they're her last
works
and they are incredibly emotional and
mean a lot to me
we are selling them
and we're selling them because
she would want them sold
and
is it unreasonable
to start debating
at twenty five thousand dollars
for a dead artist with two works
for Patricia Dillon original
what about fi here's here's what I'll
say
tell me
on social media
the amount of money you are willing to
pay for these paintings
I don't really want them they don't fit
the color scheme in my homes no they
don't fit the color scheme in my homes
my aunt said you want them I said no I'm
working with designers
we can't fit it in I've spoken to these
people and
it's there's very tough because there's
a whole scheme there's things that
highlight other things and things colors
that bounce off you people I couldn't
even explain it to you but it's just not
going to work and get the other one up
with the palm trees I think it's a
little stronger
um
so again if you want these Patricia
Dylan Originals we can make but it's
going to cost
money I don't think it should be free
this is a recently deceased artist who
has two works
could we do a gallery show with two
works you could right like an exhibition
yeah yes yes well that might happen
I mean I have an art dealer I should
call
no I have I don't think she'll answer
but I I genuinely have an art dealer who
because I like art
I like art and
hi Sophia how are you good how are you
good let me ask you a question this is
crazy my mother was kind of like an
artist she painted two things she's
recently deceased uh oh I appreciate it
she fought a long hard battle but she's
got these two like beautiful things I
just want to show them to you I don't
know
I want to show them to you because I
don't know what you could do with them
but like you know she was schizophrenic
and I know I mean not to be crass about
it but I know some of the art World
likes stuff like that yeah you know what
I mean because
[Music]
yes well and that's the thing because I
think it unlocks something that's a
little brilliant and there might be
someone you know that I mean not even to
monetize I'm not concerned about the
money but somebody might look at this
and go there's some real value in it
because of the schizophrenia
send it to me I'd love to see you yes
all right thank you so much I appreciate
it
right thank you
are we not living in a folks are we not
living in a great world folks are we not
living in a great world
I mean the art world is it not fun
Savage she's a Savage she's a nut
I'm gonna send these [__] paintings to
this person
this demon and we're gonna sell them to
some rich [__]
but not the sacklers not the set not
them
[Music]
not them I'm gonna sell my dead
schizophrenic mother's paintings because
the system's good but not the sacklers
my art dealer likes that she goes let's
pimp out those synapses firing but not
quite meeting up but not the sacrifice
not good the sacklers
but these are on the Block they're going
to the block [__] you you know what
you're not messaging on social media
we're gonna do a show this [__] she's
legit legit this [__] she's legit legit
you know it we're doing a show for my
dead mother's art
we're doing the show of my dead mother's
art if you're not into it you're not
into it but people like that it's a
schizophren you you you you [__]
Normie Minds can't a [__] comprehend
because what my mother's painting there
she's not really painting a sailboat and
palm trees what she's but and you know
what we need to do we need to kind of
dress these up a little bit right yeah
these could sell for a hundred thousand
each if I get them I'll get my aunt to
send me them and then instead of them
just being these like shitty things in
the middle of it we'll put like a a
bloody stencil of Richard Nixon's face
and I swear to God I'm not kid you put a
bloody stencil of Nixon's face and Let
it bleed and go she's a Vietnam era
schizophrenic
spell it out shell it out
absolutely true
it's it's amazingly true
I'm I'm actually to be honest with you
I'm I'm sad there's only two two let me
call my aunt because frankly we might be
getting more and I I I am praying to God
there's more give me more
what if we glued the Beanie Babies onto
them
what if we glued the Beanie Babies on hi
Donna very quick quick question can't
really talk long are those two paintings
of my mother are those the only
paintings she's done or those her only
works
wait say that set up again those two
paintings that my mother did are those
her only works
um I might have one of my own you know
that I have somewhere that I packed and
brought I'll get all of her works I want
to do a gallery show but all right I'll
I'll
just like the pine tree get them all get
them all get them all I'll call you back
thank you we're in it baby
retards they just got out of the U.S
open
start
stenciling Richard Nixon's bloody face
or some crap they'll like on my mother's
kind of boring
landscape that are kind of uninspiring
start stenciling something kind of banks
geared up sex it up
let's do a gallery show of my uh dead
schizophrenic mother's art It's My
Mother by the way people that may be
offended by this or think this is
cold-hearted there is nobody that would
want her work to sell
how do you say posthumously there's
nobody that would want her art to sell
posthumously more than my mother nobody
my mother would be happy that I'm using
uh the art that we found in her mental
institution to uh enrich myself and if
you don't have a mother like that then
you got to get a new mama you got to get
a new mother they want they want their
work appreciated and it doesn't have to
be in their lifetime that's a great
thing about art
and if you think I'm kidding about this
you don't know me and have not watched
this show there will be a gal I will do
a gallery show in New York City if this
woman I will you have to just stencil
the faces get me maybe a Henry Kissinger
Nixon we got to do something we got it's
Vietnam it's retro her mind was ruined
she was a hippie and it was fun but her
mind got you know because we gotta sell
to the rich hippie contingent
they're older now they're rich they're
wandering around Malibu or Soho
uh these are the people that you know
were these free love wild types you know
um and and uh you know they're really
excited about Pete budget
I like pink bootage I like mayor Pete
but you know these are the people that
were doing like you know they were
having five sums with Country Joe and
the Fish you know but now they're
excited about mayor P you know it's like
life life can be long sometimes and
that's the problem but
these people that you know those are the
people that we're going for with kind of
that 60s give me a little warplane you
put a war plane in the middle of one of
these A stenciled warplane in red that
it looks like blood I'm telling you
right now we're in that's all art is
it's fake
it's not real